Film Courage: So your debut novel The Thirteenth
Continuum sold and then at some point now
you have a three-book deal (which that was
the first book of the three) and it’s being
turned into a film?
Jennifer Brody, Author: Yeah, we’re working
on that.
So my background is that I used to work in
Film and TV development.
And actually before I even sold it to a publisher,
I had producers that were working on it.
It has always had a lot of interest from a
lot of producers.
The first set of producers wanted to do it
for TV and we were sort of working for them.
But at a certain point they weren’t being
super effective and we kind of felt like going
more in the film direction, so I switched
to a different producer and she’s been great.
We’re working on packing it into a film.
So they have a deal at Warner Brothers.
And then now we’re looking at writers and
directors because in the environment of right
now it really helps to have a package and
to go in with a package and there are a couple
of reasons why I think that’s good.
But one of them is that I don’t want to
rush and do a bad version of the film.
I’ve worked enough in Hollywood and worked
on enough big book adaptations like LORD OF
THE RINGS and the GOLDEN COMPASS that I know
it really matters how you put it together.
And also, it’s one thing just to option
a book.
You can do that but then there is something
we call development hell where it just kind
of gets stuck and it never gets made.
So the more you have attached and the more
you go in with, the more likely it is that
you’re going to be actually able to make
the film because I don’t just want to option
it and have it sit there are so many fabulous
books and famously popular books that have
never been made that sold for a lot a money
that studios have.
Things like Justin Cronin’s The Passage
is a good example and it just hasn’t been
made.
It’s been years and years.
So I kind of want to do it in a way that really
does it justice so I’m not really in a rush,
I want to do it right.
Film Courage: Well so the second book is coming
out November 1st?
[Editor’s note: it’s currently available].
Jennifer Brody: Yes.
Film Courage: And tell me the title again?
Jennifer Brody: It’s called Return of the
Continuums.
Film Courage: And then you have a third book
which you’re finishing up now as we speak.
Jennifer Brody: Yes.
I am finishing it up now and that will come
out in probably the end of May next year and
it’s called The United Continuums.
So that’s the other things that’s nice
about the series is that with each book is
an opportunity and it really kind of drives
attention and drives readership and there’s
a whole marketing effort, so it’s kind of
nice because you don’t have one book and
that kind of gets forgotten and you’re left
behind each time you’re going out with a
new book it’s bringing them all kind of
together and you see a lot of times these
things build over time.
Readership builds, popularity builds and we
can all cite really famous series where they
weren’t big until later.
There’s a great piece by the author, he
wrote Percy Jackson series [Rick Riordan]
which were made into films.
And I think he said it was two full years
after the first book came out that they first
had an inkling that it was going to be a huge
hit.
But for two years it wasn’t selling much
and they weren’t sure.
He was doing signings and nobody was showing
up but it was a building process, like they
really believed in it and they really worked
hard.
So it can take time.
And the other thing to remember with the book
and I’m sort of experiencing this now is
that it’s not like a film where everyone
will go opening day and see it and the be
talking about it to their friends.
Even if people buy it close to when it comes
out, it might not get read instantly.
A lot of us (and this includes me) have a
ton of books in our queue and a lot of things.
And it doesn’t mean that we’re not going
to read it.
But it might be a month or two later that
I finally do and so you start to see that
even a couple months after it’s been out
people are finally like “Oh my gosh, I finally
read this.”
And you start to hear and all of the sudden
more people start to hear.
So it’s not like an opening day phenomenon
and the other cool thing about books is they
exists and once they’re in the world, they’re
in the world a long time.
So you start to see them popping up in libraries
and popping up.
That’s the nice thing about Young Adult
is that libraries are huge for us.
Schools are huge for us.
School libraries are huge for us.
And there also a lot of kids that can’t
really afford or don’t have the budgets
to buy books so they’re waiting to get them
from their library, which I think is fantastic.
I was that kid, so I totally understand that.